all right let's start welcome everyone
good morning
I hope you have your coffee with you
this is this is going to be a pretty
technical
presentation my name is and this session
is about git hidden gems
now before we start I'd like to ask a
few questions so number one
who here is uh new to git maybe you use
it but you haven't been using it for a
long time just raise your hand
okay okay a couple of you how many here
are
let's say I've been using it for a few
years and I feel like they are
proficient but they they don't they
haven't looked into the advanced stuff
okay that's like most of you
and how many here are git Gods git
Masters
okay couple of you
so my goal here today is for there to be
at least one new thing that you didn't
know about git so when you leave this
session you should have learned at least
one new thing and if you already knew
everything I'm telling you about then
look me up afterwards because we might
have a hobby in common
okay so let's get started what gems you
might wonder is it isn't it like a
regular version control system
well yes
and no you see git is a bit like a swift
Swiss army knife uh it's a tool that you
all recognize I mean it has an obvious
purpose uh but it's all it's also more
than that it has a few tools hidden away
that you might not even know what you're
for but they're there
so yeah so git is the Swift Swiss army
knife of Version Control Systems and yes
I'm quoting myself
so my goal today is to show you the
tools that are hidden inside this you
know tool everyday tool in order to
improve your daily workflow
but first let's address the elephant in
the room shall we what with this ASCII
art
well git is a tool that was designed to
be used from the terminal from the
command line
and that's always going to be that way
even though there are a very good
graphical guise built on top of it
uh some good some bad you know but you
know they do the job but if you really
want to take advantage of git's full
potential
you need to be using it from the command
line so yes welcome to the terminal this
entire presentation is going to be from
the command line
and yes that includes even the slides
and you wouldn't believe
how long it took me to draw that
so let's keep it up a few more seconds
big and there you go
so what's the game plan
we have a screen
we divide it into two parts
on the rights well my left
you're right
yes or the other way around one side
we're going to have the terminal
on the right or left the other side
we're going to have some text that
explains what's going on with some more
ASCII graphics
okay so that's the game plan because
you're going to need some kind of
project to work on so the project is a a
calculator of course but it doesn't
really matter we're not going to look at
much of the code but it's a calculator
it's written in node because why not and
typescript just to give you an idea what
what's the source code gonna be like
so let's get started with the first gem
which I call pretty logs
now you guys already know about git log
now it shows you the history of our
commits
now this view is fine but we can do
better than that because it turns out
that git head git log has an option
called pretty
and if you use that option you can
customize the output of git log
so for example we can say git log pretty
and the parameter is a bunch of
placeholders for the different pieces of
metadata that are part of a commit so
for example if we just wanted to print
the summary that is the first line of a
commit message we will say percent s and
then we just look at the message
now of course you can do much more than
this so
let's do something more interesting
where we say pretty
and then we change the color to red
then we want to print out the hash code
but not the long one you know the one
the one that you see everywhere we just
want the abbreviated hash code which is
usually the sixth first six seven uh
character so it's lowercase h
then let's reset the color
now let's change the color again to
Yellow
and now I want to print the branch
references that are point or that or the
tags whatever references are pointing to
that commit
now if you had to guess what the
placeholder for the references is
what will you say
r
but unfortunately it's D
because you know
it's git
so let's reset the color again
then let's have a space and then now we
print the familiar summary which is the
first line in the commit message now
let's change the color again and let's
make cyan and now we open up parenthesis
and now we want to print the commit date
or or the auth or the date however we
want to print the date relative to now
so we say AR
and then we reset the color again
and this is what you get
okay
so this is much much better
you know it's uh more succinct can you
still read the font if I do like that
yeah cool so um
of course I mean all you need to do to
take advantage of this is just you just
type this every time
Emma you get fast after a while
now obviously not there are there is
another feature which you may or may not
know about in in git which is called
aliases
now an alias is a word that you
associate to a command plus a bunch of
options you can even have a shell
function Associated to an alias which
takes parameters so you can take it as
far as you want
so let's write an Alia so instead of
typing this every time
let's just copy that
that string
so we go like this and we copy that
and then we say git log no git config
Global because aliases are part of the
configuration
and then you say Alias Dot and then the
name of your area so in this case let's
call it LG of course it has to be
something that doesn't already exist
and then you say what command so log and
then pretty
and then you just paste in
the string that we are that we had so
now I can say guitar G
of course and then you can have your own
customized view of the log
pretty useful stuff did you guys know
about this how many here are new
okay maybe 20 percent
okay so let's move on to the second gem
which is stays on the theme of pretty
things because if you're gonna be on the
terminal all day like I am it might as
well look good
so pretty divs
now uh if you do
a gitif for example let's compare the
previous commit from the with the latest
one you get this which is of course I
mean the default way of looking at diffs
however
you might not know that everything
that's been piped to the to the terminal
is passed to through a program called a
pager Now the default pager for git is
less which is which is what gives you
the ability to scroll up and down with
the with the arrows or KNG
however that's not fixed it's a setting
you can change and there are a bunch of
programs out there that do pretty things
with the diff output
they improve upon it and one of them is
called Delta Now Delta
is written in Rust so that tells you
already there that it's a cool tool
so that so what you can do is that you
can just set the core.pager option to
Delta and now that is going to take care
of all the diffs for you so of course
you need to install it first which I
already did but you say git config
global
core.pager and then you say Delta
and now if you do the same div it looks
like this
and now not only do you get a you know
the plus and minuses are gone the
headers are prettier but also you get
syntax highlighting
now this is typescript so you get
synthesis lighting for your code and it
supports a bunch of different languages
so Delta is something that I would
recommend you add to your configuration
now let's move on to start changing
files let's talk about staging
so when you work with Git it's always a
good idea to make your commits
semantically consistent what does that
mean it means that if you're making a
every commit should contain one logical
change so if for example if you are
making a refactoring that should be one
commit if you are fixing a bug that
should be a separate commit separate
from the refactoring
however that's hard to do because once
you are in the code you are going to
find Opportunities to do stuff and
you're gonna do it right there right so
my maybe you do the refactoring and you
fix a bug so how do you then split those
into separate commits
of course with previous Version Control
Systems was
pretty hard if not impossible to do
unless you were really disciplined so
but in git you have the freedom to work
as you want and still have the
possibility to keep a clean history
now
what we will use in this case is the
patch option of git ad you know git add
is the command that allows you to Stage
your changes for the next commit
now what patch allows you to do it
allows you to split and just stage a
portion of a file instead of the entire
file
so how does that look like let's say
that so where I have a file called
index.ts
and let's open it with the
the only editor that you ever need
text editor which is
thanks I was afraid of someone was gonna
say emacs
or Nano
so VM of course
so now this is you know simple
typescript file which is the entry point
of this calculator program
now there are some opportunities for
improvement
so here for example
here I spot a typo because
embarrassingly enough the embarrassing
word board has two r
so so let's fix the type for shall we so
we say
we add another R so it's embarrassingly
so so and we made one change now we go
down here
and we say that for example here I like
to be this calculator to be really
academic so I don't want to say the
numbers to add instead I want to say the
add-ins
so I kind of improved on the user
feedback of the program so now I made
two changes right
I made one change over here
which is a fixing a typo
and then I made another change over here
which is kind of improving on the US
it's kind of a feature you could say
so how do I keep those two separate well
this is the scenario we have with the
git patch I can choose to say just stage
that portion
and leave this in my local directory for
a later commit okay
so how do we do that
first of course we need to save this and
close and then I can say git add
patch
now git is going to ask me do you want
to Stage this hunk now the word hunk
doesn't mean what you think it means
in this case the word hunk means it's
just the the word for for um in the
unified D format which believe it or not
is a standard
there is the word for a portion of a
patch which is called a hunk now do you
want to Stage this hunk and then you get
a bunch of options
which are all pretty self-explanatory
now but of course you can use the
question mark to say hey what what does
all those letters mean but believe me
when I say in this case we want to
split this into smaller chunks so we say
s
so let's split and now I get the same
question however you see this time it's
one of two hunks
and then it's the same question do you
want to Stage this song and then I say
yes that's the first change we want to
Stage this hunk no
now if I do a good status you see the
file is simultaneously staged and
unstaged
now you might wonder how do I look at
what's about to be committed
well I say gitif staged
how do I look at what's left in my
working directory I can just say gitif
okay
cool stuff now
bonus tip the parts also work works for
undoing things
so for example
let's open it up again and let's let's
make a couple of more changes for
example here
I'm gonna add this is documentation
and then down here I'm going to say this
is a comment
just make two two different changes
now let's say that I regret one of those
I want to remove it from my local
changes
then I can say git restore
[Music]
and then I get the same question however
this time is do you want to discard this
hunk from the work tree
and then it's the same kind of options
right so I can say yeah split this do
you want to discard this and I say no do
you want to discard this and I say yes
and then it's there are other change of
course and I don't want to discard that
so now if I say get if I got rid of
the comment
cool stuff did you guys know about this
how many years knew about this
also the restore
okay W yeah
all right
let's move on
with more staging stuff now once you
start splitting commits
the next question becomes well
every commit should be consistent it
should not break the build it should not
fail the test I should be confident
enough that if I P cherry pick a commit
from another Branch or if I you know
merge something
I should not worry about the the build
being broken
so how do I ensure now that I'm
splitting commits and I have changes in
my local directory and I have changes
that are staged how do I ensure that
what staged by itself doesn't break
anything
so you need to kind of isolate that in
order to maybe run the test locally
well it turns out that a good way to do
that is to use stash now stash is the
command that takes away stuff from the
working directory and you know
stashes it away
however stash has a nice option called
keep index
which allows you basically to remove
everything from your working directory
stash it away but keep whatever was
already staged
so in this case I can say git stash save
but keep the index
and now if I say get Thief I don't have
any changes left in my working directory
however if I look at what staged that's
still there
okay
so now I can maybe run the tests
and verify that what I'm about to commit
by itself with no other changes it works
which of course it does because it's
just a fixing a typo but you get the
point
and now at this point I can commit
and I say fixes a typo
and now once I'm done of course I can
get back whatever I had stash with Git
stash pop
and now
I have my changes back okay cool
does anyone here use this technique
couple of you okay cool
so let's move on with two more gems
searching
get us some really powerful searching
facilities
it's allow you to allow you to search
for commits that modified lines it's
more than just blame
so for example
one of the most powerful features for
searching is called pickaxe because you
go spelunking you know in the history
with your pickaxe
and there is one so for in pickaxe what
to do is that you look for commits that
either add or remove a line that matches
your
search pattern so it could be something
that contains wildcard or it could also
be a regular expression
um but the simple one is with just wild
cards so for example in this case I
would like to know what's the commit
that originally introduced the typo that
we just fixed
so right at the command line I can and
of course I can use my Alias so I can
say LG
and then I say s and then in bar Russian
with one r
and I get two two commits back
of course I get the commit that we just
made because we modified a line we
removed a line that contained the typo
and then we have another commit which is
the commit that originally introduced
that line
so let's take a look at it briefly
and indeed this was the commit that
introduced the line okay pretty cool
searching stuff
through the code
bonus tip
and this is gonna I hope this is gonna
blow your mind because it blew mine you
can search by function name
what's the function name well it's
whatever it's a method in C sharp it's a
function in JavaScript
whatever has curly braces and it looks
like a c style function basically
so for example I know that in this code
base I have a file called calculator
which has a function called add
now I want to get a list of all the
commits that somehow modify that
function
regardless of the line regardless of the
line number whatever
so
I can do I use the L option so I can say
git log l colon then the name of the
function which is ADD and then the path
to the file that contains it so
calculate calculator.ts
bam I get the commit that introduced the
function now there are no more
commissions that modify it but you know
they will also appear right there
did you know about this
okay one two okay cool do you like it do
you think it's useful
yeah so remember this works for any c
style languages so in case of C sharp
that would be a method or Java
or uh in the JavaScript which is the
script version of java
uh yours it works with function
so
let's move on
to automation
well spoiler I have nine gems so we are
about halfway through
and another spoiler is that we the gems
that we already seen it a little bit
these gems kind of build upon each other
so we're going to be using previous
stuff to do more stuff so we already be
using the LG Alias for example and we're
going to be using more of the other
stuff as well
so automation
now when you work you
off more often than not find out that
you there is a change that you wish you
would have made earlier
so for example
um
I don't know you are you are about to
change the file that you know it should
have been part of a previous commit
so what do you do well usually if you
want to keep your history clean which
you should
you make a new commit and then you go
back and do an interactive rebase and
squash the commit into a previous one so
that it looks like the change was
already made from the beginning right
now this kind of workflow is so popular
that there are features in git to
automate it to speed it up
one such feature is called
Auto squash
and you might wonder why is this not on
by default well it's not so you need to
enable it first
so you say git config
Global rebase dot Auto squash
true
now what this does is it allows you to
speed up this workflow that I talked
about of amending previous commit so
now what do we have
we have
a change this addent
let's say that we want to make this
change part of the commit that
originally introduced this line okay so
we want to amend that earlier commit but
we don't know which which one that is
and also we have two changes we don't
know we don't want to commit this change
we just want to commit that one and
squash it into a previous commit so
let's use all the stuff that we've been
looking at today right so far
so first we need to do a patch commit
right
so we said you want to Stage this no do
you want to Stage this yes perfect so
now we have just changed that change now
let's find the commit that originally
introduced that line
of course we use the pickaxe with our
together with our LG alias so we say s
and then the num this was called numbers
to add what was the commit to introduce
that well it's this one
perfect let's grab the kumitash
now what we do is that instead of Simply
committing
our change
we say commit and then dash dash fix up
and then we give it the hash of the
commit that we want this to be squashed
into later
are you with me yeah
and what happens next is that of course
you get a regular commit however the
commit message contains the word fix up
with an exclamation mark so you can
think in your head like fix up
and then
you get it you get the basically the
same
a commit message of the previous commit
now once you have a bunch of those of
course you can and now at this point you
can keep going with your workflow you
can do more changes and if you realize
that you have a change that should have
been made earlier you do the same thing
you do a fixed up commit and then you
keep going so you end up with a bunch of
no proper real commits and a bunch of
fixed up commits all mixed together
now once you are done in the end you do
one interactive rebase
so you say gitree bay is interactive
probably the C Dash I
and in my case I'm going to do it for
the whole history so I'm gonna say start
from the root you know but you're
probably going to say from the branching
point
and oh
has this ever happened to you you want
to do a rebase but you have modified
files in a working directory
so you need to stash them
well this this is a so common problem
that there is a feature for it called
Auto stash
with capital S it's important that the
budget doesn't work
so without the stash of course it's also
something you need to enable
so you say git config global
rebase dot Auto stash remember the
capital s
true
and now I think you can guess what it
does right
so once you do an Interactive rebase
you didn't see it we're gonna see it
later but it allowed us to do to do the
rebase
so you see what happens here the fix up
commit
has been moved into the right spot just
below the commit you want to squash it
into and the action has been changed
into fix up so as I told you before you
can have a whole bunch of this
that you make and they are going to be
moved into the right spot
and the action already changed so all
you have to do here you just have to
quit and Save
and the rebase is done
and you see what happened here created
the auto stash
it allowed us to use to do the rebase
and then it reapplied the auto stash so
the changes in my working directory are
back
and of course I have nothing in the
stash
so that's really useful
and also if you look at the history
we see that our fix up commit is gone
it was the latest one now it's been
incorporated into this so let's take a
look at how this looks like
and you see that it says the add-ins so
it looks like I wrote that from the
beginning
okay
lots of automation stuff
let's keep going with something visual
the dot notation does anyone know about
the dot mutation
what about the dot dot notation
okay one what about the dot dot dot
notation
no one it is a real thing
so it's two dots or three dots we're
going to look at the two dots today
so
um what does it do well usually
you are going to always let me just get
rid of that change
you are always going to be asking the
question what commits are in this branch
that are not in that Branch usually you
are in a topic Branch or in a pull
request Branch you want to say you want
to know what commits are here that are
not in the main branch
uh a quick way to do that is to use git
log together with the dot dot notation
so for example let's say that you have
this situation
you have a topic branch and a main
branch
now what you want to know is what
commits are in the topic branch that are
not in the main branch
okay
so in order to do that you say
git log
main dot dot topic this means
show me the commits that
are not here
but that are here
so the first reference is always the
negative so not here but there
okay so in this case let's switch to a
topic Branch so I have a feature ADD
test script that's a topic Branch what
commits are here that are not in main so
I can say git LG main dot dot
feature at test script and I get this
list
now of course the opposite is very easy
if I want to ask the question what
commits are in Main
that are not in topic
all right I just reverse it to the two
the two references so I can say top not
in topic dot dot but in Main
so in this case I can say guitar G
not here
but that are in Main and I get that
okay of course instead of saying the
name of the branch you can say head
because head is always the branch you
are currently having a working tree
now combine this with a the aliases
feature
and we can start we can start doing some
interesting things
for example let's say that we have a
lilies called new that shows you what
commits are new in my branch that are
not in the main branch
so how do you do that you can say git
config global
Global then you say Alias dot new
and then you can you can reference
you can reference aliases from other
aliases
you could not do that in the beginning
so that inversion I think they added in
1.8
something like that but before that you
cannot do that you can reference aliases
so you can say LG
and then you can say
what's not in main or master or whatever
you or default or whatever you call your
no long running main branch
dot dot head which is the branch you're
currently standing on
now what about the opposite
I can have an alias called missing so I
can say git global
Alias dot missing and then I just
reverse the two things not here but in
Main
now when I'm in a topic Branch I can say
get new this is the new stuff what am I
missing this is the stuff I'm missing
I use this all the time
it's like automatic get new get missing
cool aliases to to have in your git
config
okay
let's go into the
advanced stuff rebase onto
have you heard about rebase onto
a couple of you okay do you use it every
day
one that's impressive okay what does
rebase you already know what it does you
know changes it changes the base of your
branch into another base
what does we base on to do well rebase
onto allows you to take a chunk of a
branch a portion of a branch so it
doesn't start from the branching point
you can say whatever range of commits
within a branch and you transferred it
to another base
you can do you could say Branch surgery
so rebase onto
how is this useful well let's say that
you have a situation like this which is
the one we have
and we have this commit over here
that we have now amended we made a fix
up if you remember
we so we changed it
it means that the whatever topic Branch
was based on top of that now contains
the old version of that commit right
while the main branch now has the new
version
which is exactly
what we have if you look
let me see here
if I can do git new
get missing do you guys spot something
interesting in these two
we give you a hint
so what's new in our branch
is actually
the old commit
and what's in main it's the new amended
commit
right
so now how can we get rid of this
situation
we want to be what we want to do
basically is we want to take these two
commits
over here
and we want to move them so that they
become based off of Main
thus removing this commit tool together
so this is what we want to do take those
two move them on top of Main and get rid
of that old B
so you can do that by using
um rebase onto
so how does the syntax look like
well it's very simple you say gitree
base onto
and then you say new base
and then you say what was the old base
and you give it as a second parameter so
in in our case
it's going to look like this
rebase on to main the new base what was
the old base it was the old B
which is going to be excluded
so in our topic Branch we say rebase
well first we we need to find the main
the old
B which is
this one
so let's grab the committash you can
also say origin Main in this case
because there is a branch reference
sorry based on to main what was the old
base it was B
and now it's just one operation
I have no longer B here
I just have the new commits so what I
did once again I took those two commits
and I moved them up
so that they're based off of Main
and this way I got rid of the old base
which is B
so that's rebase onto and it's a very
quick way to also delete commits in a
branch like let's say that you have 10
commits and there are two in the middle
that you want to remove you just say
replace onto what was the old com the
first of the old commits we want to
remove and what is the new base you want
to use and you basically remove commits
that are in the middle of a branch
I know it takes some getting used to
once well now you know about rebase onto
so you can explore it further and
because there is another uh another
variant of it based onto with three
arguments where you take a just a chunk
in the in the middle of a branch and
then move it somewhere else
so I encourage you to look it up and
start adding it into your your toolbox
because it's very useful
of course in the end we end up with a
linear history like this
which is what we have
so we are actually really ahead of
schedule
so let's talk about gem number eight
which is the reflog how many of you here
know about reflog
okay a couple of you
so what is the ref Vlog well
git doesn't only keep track of your file
files is also keeps track of it its own
files and the git's own files are the
references the branches or the tags
now every time a branch changes
so you make a new commit or you rebase
or you reset
git remembers what commit was that
Branch pointing to before this operation
okay
and that list of changes is called a
reflog now every branch has its own
reflog which you can get to by saying
git reflog and then the branch name so
for example
featured at this
test
script
and you get the ref log for that
particular branch
now you might actually let's look at
Main sort of log which is a little bit
easier
so in the main this is its ref log what
you see is that every entry has the name
of the branch then the at and then a
number which increases
now this is the higher the number the
older the entries so the latest one is
always zero that's where we are at now
and the oldest ones not are the higher
numbers
and you see what kind of changes is it
you see the fixed subcommit we made the
other commit
resetting rebasing
so these are the commits that that
Branch was pointing to before those
operations
so
how can we use and another thing to know
is that head
which is the reference that points to
the the branch you are currently have
checked out
head also has its own reflog which you
get to by saying just get reflog
and this basically contains the same
thing however it's had instead of the
branch name
and another thing that reflog for head
contains is every time you move a branch
so every time you do a checkout or a
switch
the left log for head remembers what
branch did you have checked out before
which is something that you can use and
I'm gonna show you
but first let's look at how can you use
the ref log
well let's say the day of situation like
this which is the usual situation
now we did a rebase so now we the
history looks like this
but what if we change our mind
now the rebase is complete it's finished
but now we want to go back to where
things were before the rebase
well how do you do that I mean the old
commit is no longer visible in the
history if you do git log
however it's still there somewhere
and what's pointing to the old in our
case D before a rebase
what's pointing to it is of course the
ref log for that for that branch and if
that was the last operation we did
it's going to be number one because zero
is where we are right now and the
previous
reference the previous commit that
Branch was pointing to was is number one
so now that we have a way to get to that
commit it becomes pretty trivial to undo
things because now we made a rebase I
can just say reset
which is how you change the branch
reference to something else
in this case you say hard because you
really mean it
no you say hard because you also want to
change your working directory and the
head reference so that everything is
synchronized
what do you reset it to well you reset
it to feature ADD test script at one
and now if I say get new
I get the old B back the one who I got
ridden off before
so rare life log is basically gits
Universal undo machine
now you might wonder how long are these
things being kept around in the reflog
well usually is 30 days
so entries older than 30 days are going
to be dropped out of the ref log now
actually scratch that I think it's 90
days
entries older than 90 days are going to
be no all this one that just get removed
from the left log
and of course it's a setting that you
can change
now keep in mind that git has its own
garbage collection
so commits that are not being referenced
by anything like in this case once we
did the rebase there was nothing
pointing to the old B apart from the ref
log
so once it also drops out of the ref log
then there is really nothing pointing to
the old commit and the garbage
collection is going to remove it
together with the whole files Associated
to it right
the blobs and stuff
so that's good to know the reflog stays
there for uh for a few months
so you can always go back
and bonus Tip since we have a bit of
extra time
what if you don't know what entry
something is in the ref log
now we can combine
all that we already know for example
remember the pickaxe
well you can say git LG s and then some
word
that was in the files
so for example
I don't know the audience
and then if you add walk ref logs
this tells git L log to not only look at
the history
with that pickaxe but also look at the
ref log
and now I don't get anything because
there is nothing there
but always add ref log another way you
another thing you can do is that what if
I remember the commit message I don't
remember the change but I remembered
some word in the commit message
then you can say git LG grep
and then you can say what was in the
commit message a word for example you
can say I don't know add
and then you say Walker F logs
and now you get all the commits that
contain the word add
however you get them from the the ref
log
all right
and that's what we do right now right we
reseted the topic Branch to the entry in
the in the um in the ref log and now
we're back to that situation again
we're doing really good on time
so let's look at our last
um last but not least gem
which is my personal favorite
does anyone you know about Rivera
no
oh no okay
so then it means that someone here knew
about everything
okay look me up afterwards
what is that what on Earth is errored
well
it stands for re reuse recorded
resolution
now we all know merge conflicts are a
fact of life
and they are they happen more often than
not and have you ever been in a
situation where you have to resolve the
same conflict multiple times
yeah it happens
now there is one part there are many
reasons why you might have to do that
but one particular reason that comes to
mind is there is a no very common
workflow
that is being used in the Linux
development Linux kernel development
which is called the test merge workflow
so let's say that you have a topic
branch which is kind of long running so
you're you keep it around for a longest
time
however your main branch is also going
to move ahead
what you want to do is that you want to
make sure that what you are doing
doesn't conflict with whatever is
happening in the main branch so what do
you do you regularly do merges
from the main branch into your own topic
branch
however you don't keep all of those
merge commits around because they will
clutter the history
what you do is that you do a merge and
then you don't commit it so
you basically do a merge but not con do
you do not continue until the merge
commit actually is created you just
interrupted before
well what gives you the opportunity to
do is to see if there are any conflicts
right you just do a merge are there any
conflicts yes
if you have a rarely enabled you can
resolve those conflicts
the resolution is going to be recorded
and then you can get rid of the merge
commit but the resolution is still
recorded for later
and if you keep doing this regularly
you're going to be solving the conflicts
you know at regular intervals then at
the end once you are ready to merge
you're going to have of course the same
conflict because you deleted the merge
commits
however all the resolutions are going to
be reapplied
okay
so the test merge workflow is pretty
pretty useful to do
if you have a long running topic branch
and a fast moving main branch
okay
so how do you do it of course you need
to enable it first
so config Global enabled
true yeah it's always funny every time
and remember that nothing is recorded
until you enable it so previous merge
conflict that you resolved those are not
going to be recorded however there is a
python script that tries to recreate
to go to look at the merge commits and
trying to you know record the resolution
but you know it's hit and miss
so from the point when you enable it
then it starts recording and how does it
look like
well we are in our feature branch
let's say that we want to re merge it
into main okay
so we switch to Main
and then we say merge feature
ADD test script
now we have a conflict
but notice in the output
it says recorded pre-image for the file
that has the conflict
now this is Rarity that's printing that
out
now of course we can take a look at the
div and you see how Delta formats the
emerge conflict in a pretty way makes it
really easy to see
what's what of course the line that's
conflicting is this the add-ons
in our topic Branch it says still the
old one this is B conflicting it's this
is the old B conflicting with the Newbie
right
so the numbers to add and the add-ins
which one do we want of course we want
the new one the one that's in head
which is the target of the merge
so there is a quick way to resolve this
conflict we just say ReStore hours we
want our version of the file not theirs
which is the topic branch
and then we say index
perfect
now we have resolved the conflict you
need to tell that this is the resolution
and how do you do that you do it by
staging
the um
the file with the resolution
and then you can just say merge continue
of course you got the message and then
you save and notice here recorder
resolution for that file
okay now let's say that we change our
mind
we want to remove the merge commit
which is what we will do in the test
merge flow
and you say git reset hard go back to
the parent of our latest commit
that's little character there the carrot
sign means the parent of the previous
commit of head
so let's reset now now we have no no
longer a merge commit we are back to
this situation over here
and let's say that now we want to
instead we want to rebase so that we get
a linear history instead
now remember every base is still emerge
it's just that every commit is being
applied one at a time instead of merging
two commits
so if we switch back to our feature
brand
and we do a rebase to Main
we're going to get the same conflict
again however this time we get hey it
was resolved using a previous resolution
now remember git is very conservative it
doesn't really it doesn't just reapply a
previous resolution and go ahead and
continue and no complete done because of
course things change in a previous
resolution might be obsolete now
so it always stops and gives you the
chance to check does the resolution
still apply
so you can
take a look at the file
SRC index you see that it reapplied the
add-ons
like we have done previously so this
looks good
let's confirm that it does by adding it
to the index and then we say rebase
continue
and now we're done
okay and this of course works well other
ones I have I can show you one thing
more
that is then what do you do if the
resolution is obsolete
how do you remove a previously recorded
resolution
well once again
now we're going to use what we already
learned
now we have rebased how do we get back
to before the rebase
what do we use
the ref log right
so we can just reset hard feature at the
script at one because this is the last
thing we just did
and now we're back to before the rebase
now let's do the rebase again
of course we run into the same conflict
however this time the resolution doesn't
apply anymore
so what do we do we say git red forget
SRC index
and he says
I forgot the previous resolution and now
you need to of course resolve it again
and do the same thing again right
which is gonna which is going to record
the new resolution afterwards
now you might wonder where are those
recorded Solutions well of course they
are in the git directory there is a
directory called RR cache why not RR
cash
I don't know
you tell me but that is where they are
and there is a directory
of course into into that there is
a directory for every um and now we are
now we forgot about it so there are no
files
so let's continue and look at how it
looks like once you resolve the
resolution
yeah the file is already being changed
so now in theory we will apply a
different resolution but in this case
we're gonna keep it the same
and then you say rebase continue
and it was uh and it was rebased
and now hopefully it has recorded
no because I actually did not never mind
what happens is that in that directory
there are going to be three files one
with the one side of the conflict one
with the other side of the conflict and
one with the final resolution and that's
how git recognizes that the same
conflict appears again if each side is
the same and it reapplies the third file
which was the resolution
all right let's sum this up
we have looked at
nine gems first one was pretty logs
use the pretty option of git log to
customize the way you look at history
then we looked at pretty divs highly
encourage you to add Delta to Azure
pager makes life really easier when you
look at diffs
staging with the partial partial staging
with the git add patch and restore paths
to individually remove changes from your
working directory
then we have the searching facilities
with pickaxe look at commits that either
add or remove a line that matches some
text or some while irregular expression
automation remember about Auto squash
and auto stash to speed up the workflow
where you go back and amend previous
commits
the dot notation
allows you to compare branches what's in
this Branch that's not in another branch
and then you can associate those two
aliases
to create the new and missing aliases to
quickly determine what's new and what's
missing in your topic brands
then we looked at rebase onto which is
the advanced version of the base where
you take portions of a branch and move
them into a new base
which is a good way to get rid of
commits that you no longer want in a
branch
then we looked at the gits universal
undo machine which is the ref vlog keeps
track of every Branch what commits they
were pointing to and you can use that
together with reset to go back to
previous States
and you can use the warcraft logs option
to to do searches like we did with
pickaxe but you can search in the ref
log as well Warcraft logs
and finally a red data which is a reuse
recorder resolution
git remembers how you solve conflicts
and automatically reapplies the same
solution once it sees that the conflict
is the same on both sides
now
there are many more features like that
in git you can imagine
of course I cannot show you everything
so I have a course out on plural site
called Advanced get tips and tricks
that covers some of this stuff and stuff
that I wouldn't I wouldn't have time to
show you today
so if you have plural site I highly
encourage you to check that out
and with that
I'd like to thank you for your attention
foreign